vous allez comprendre que leur bec
terriens ce moment incroyable a beaucoup
d'attentes et aussi le travail sur la
pensée qui a fait fondre et logique
juste remarquable parce qu'il ya nous ne
sommes pas des cobayes
nous sommes des êtres et de penser mais
il faut que on synchronise et que notre
corps se synchronise avec nos pensées si
on pouvait tout sublimé et n'être qu'un
être pensant son digestion sans rien ce
serait génial mais moi j'ai pas encore
réussi à transmuter les intolérances
alimentaires alors ceux qui pensent que
je vais vous dire un secret que tu
bouffes tu bouffes pas tu crèves quand
même on est d'accord il faut bien mourir
de quelque chose non et puis si c'était
dangereux ça sort s est ce qu'on vous
entendez dire et pourtant il ya plein de
scandales sanitaires qui arrive 20 ans
30 ans après quarante ans après donc là
vous avez beaucoup de chance ici d'être
aujourd'hui parce que bon vous n'êtes
pas forcément sensibilisé à cette notion
parce que on est ici dans le monde de la
pensée
mais cette pensée elle a un ventre et on
va le voir que finalement le cerveau ici
tu peux forcément là il situe là oui
c'est l'écran mais le disque dur est là
alors voulait mourir comment comme ça ou
alors sereinement dans votre lit après
avoir fait une vie pleine de vitalité
plein de projets plein de créativité
c'est un choix et ce choix il se trouve
qui nous appartient alors avant ne
savait pas parce que ça fait très
longtemps que on n'arrivait pas à aller
dans le ventre des gens d'ailleurs
l'intestin grêle
on arrive à avoir des petites photos
pour faire des petites prises d'écran
mais on a encore des zones aveugles et
de l'église
effectivement à donner le corps à des
cartes en disant bon vous vous occupez
du corps nous on s'occupe de l'esprit
c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu toujours une
dissociation entre la médecine qui
s'occupe du corps physique
et les toutes les pensées qui saurait
qui s'occupe de la pensée je bafouille
un peu parce que je suis obligé à
rentrer dans un cadre c'est un peu
compliqué pour moi et donc on va
comprendre que le corps il à son
fonctionnement
l'esprit effectivement va intervenir sur
son fonctionnement mais il ya des
joueurs de tennis comme ça qu'ils se
sont aperçus que ils avaient une
meilleure productivité à meilleurs
talents d'ailleurs on n'a pas gagné mais
nadal aussi et sans gluten ils sont tous
les deux sans gluten et on va le voir
alors j'ai où vous la question pourquoi
guérir alors qu'on peut prévenir et vous
ici qu'être dans la salle il ya 70% des
gens qui sont ici qui sont intolérants
au gluten sein de sabra j'ai pas si vous
rendez compte
mais ça je suis en train de faire une
étude avec des médecins anthropologue
qui sont en train d'étudier la génétique
alors bien sûr si on va pas aller dans
le tout génétique mais cette génétique
nous démontre que on va avoir des gènes
qui sont transmis par notre père et
notre mère et on a un système qui
s'appelle le système à sheila et qui va
donc nous prédisposé à certaines
maladies
et parmi celles là si on mange trop de
gluten c'est là le foyer à cause du mal
absolu sion intestinale du déclenchement
de ces maladies donc ça ce quelles sont
les maladies associées au gluten vous
avez les constipation la diarrhée donc
bien sûr tous les signes digestifs mais
il ya aussi des maladies qu'on ne
pourrait ne jamais associé aussi
digestif c'est à dire les scléroses en
plaques et la polyarthrite la thyroïde
hashimoto le diabète de type 1
le syndrome sec de gouges grosse gorgée
savez c'est bouche sèche oeil sec
les pathologies de l'intestin comme le
syndrome du côlon irritable les
gastro-entérologues il ya encore vingt
ans disent écoutez c'est dans la tête et
vous donnez un pansement gastrique et
puis il ne vous inquiétez pas
détendez-vous ça ira mieux
les cancers du côlon mais aussi les
recto colite les maladie de crohn etc
il se trouve que il ya aussi des
maladies comme la dépression et vous
allez voir d'ailleurs à ce sujet
le professeur montagnier va au mois de
juillet il va y avoir un un exposé sur
justement l'autisme la schizophrénie et
d'autres maladies neurologiques qui sont
bien sûr en interaction avec les
intestins et donc moi c'est parce que
j'ai eu des problèmes de santé
donc je suis totalement autodidacte au
départ ensuite j'ai fait des études pour
comprendre et j'ai résolu par moi même
ses problèmes de santé et je veux dire
qu'aujourd'hui à 58 ans je suis en bien
meilleure santé qu'à 20 ans parce que
j'étais une grande migraineuses j'avais
trois grammes de cholestérol et je n'ai
plus rien donc sans aller dans le détail
des statistiques en tout cas on sait que
d'ici 2030 il y aura 3 milliards 300
millions d'obèses
oui si vous allez là d'avoir la dalle
est très bien mais l'obésité c'est
vraiment le problème de civilisation
et même si on n'a pas une grosse obésité
on peut être en surpoids et le surpoids
à l'extérieur démontre le problème à
l'intérieur c'est à dire des graisses
qui vont se mettre au niveau de votre
foi et qui va occasionner beaucoup de
décès et beaucoup de maladies
donc vous avez bien vu en ce moment
comme tout arrive à être dénoncés eh
bien vous avez eu les preuves des
statines vous avez entendu parler ces
trucs anti cholestérol vous avez eu le
distilbène le médiator les margarines
vous le savez qu'elles sont bourrés
d'acides gras qu'on appelle trans c'est
à dire dans la nature les acides gras
sont 6 6 et quand on les transforme avec
les graisses hydrogénées elles
deviennent 6 trans ans l'industrie
maintenant elle vous dit oh bah
maintenant on en compte on en mettrait
très peu voire pas du tout mais ont
quand même fait manger pendant 30 ans à
des millions voire des milliards de
personnes des margarines
alors est ce qu'on a vraiment du recul
parce qu'à l'échelle de l'humanité
quand on voit la culture des céréales ça
fait que 12000 ans qu'on cultive des
céréales avant l'homme
il était chasseur cueilleur c'est à dire
que il est passé dentaire il allait au
fur et à mesure des endroits où il y
avait à manger ils chassaient y manger
des tubercules il mangeait des certains
végétaux il a fait un énorme bond avec
la découverte du feu vous savez que
notre cortex il ya plusieurs millions
d'années ne faisait que notre cerveau
pardon ne faisait que 700 grammes et
qu'aujourd'hui effet 1 kg 5
et c'est parce qu'on n'a plus besoin
justement de digérer des aliments crus
qe2 demande énormément de travail
digestif et la cuisson et les meilleurs
cuisson les chinois l'ont bien connu
depuis 6000 ans la cuisson à la vapeur
douce c'est la cuisson qui alterne le
moins les aliments donc on l'a fait un
bond dans l'humanité grâce à la fois la
cuisson mais on allait finalement très
bien
on veut nous faire croire que on vit
plus vieux
oui on vit plus vieux mais regardez à
partir de 60 ans dans quel état les gens
commencent à être alors bien sûr il ya
le tabac et à l'alcool la malbouffe
il ya un certain nombre de choses qui
rentrent en ligne de compte et on n'en
tient pas compte justement parce que le
carburant que vous allez mettre dans
votre corps il est essentiel c'est à
dire que je vais pas mettre du gasoil
dans une voiture qui roule au super c
pas possible
comment se fait-il que je vais faire
attention à l'huile que je vais mettre
dans le moteur de ma voiture et que je
ne fais pas attention à l'huile que je
vais ingéré ya un truc qui va pas donc
vous qui êtes ici essaie de comprendre
que sans être le les malades au tortoré
xique parce qu'aujourd'hui on qualifie
les gens qui veulent manger bio et qui
veulent faire attention à leur
alimentation
on les traite de malades orthorexiques
maintenant la biologie est là à
van sant en tout étaient biologiques on
leur parlait même pas ce que c'était
normal
mais depuis la guerre il ya eu tellement
de bouleversements et eu tellement de
pesticides des d'aliments inventée par
l'homme tous beaucoup de choses que vous
propose l'industrie agroalimentaire sont
des aliments tellement transformé où on
va à rajouter d acide ascorbique des
vitamines qui n'ont plus rien à voir
avec des vitamines naturelles qu' on ne
peut plus se synchroniser avec ces
aliments et le gluten fait partie de ces
aliments qui ont été tellement
bidouiller par l'industrie que humble et
avant avait 14 chromosomes
aujourd'hui il en a 44 nous vous savez
qu'on a 22 paires de chromosomes + 1 x x
x y
d'accord et un chromosome est défaillant
et vous est trisomique
on a absolument pas de recul pour voir
justement quel est l'impact non
seulement des organismes génétiquement
modifiés mais aussi des organismes qui
ont été tellement rétro croisés que ce
blé ce blé que l'on cultive aujourd'hui
si on ne devait rien faire pour le
laisser pousser il ne pousserait pas il
ne peut pousser kacou d'engrais qu'à
coups de pesticides et vous avez bien vu
qu'on est en train de se dé synchronisée
du vivant parce que nous sommes des
êtres symbiotique
et justement les bactéries sont bien là
pour nous le démontrer
c'est pour ça qu'on va avoir des
ballonnements c'est pour ça qu'on va
avoir un certain nombre d'éléments qui
vont faire que y'a un truc qui va pas
donc si vous n'écoutez pas votre vente
bon je poste va l'emmener dans le dans
le bon sens mais si vous avez des
ballonnements c'est déjà un premier
signe indicatif que les bactéries ne
sont plus d'accord avec vous et que ce
que vous faites ça va pas et aussi si
vous avez un problème de santé parce que
il va y avoir des causes de
déclenchement qui ne sont
pas forcément associée à des causes
alimentaire c'est à dire que si vous
n'avez pas eu la chance d'être à l'été
au départ de votre vie si vous êtes nés
par césarienne
si vous avez mangé du gluten trois fois
par jour ce qui est la norme dans nos
pays
si vous avez pris beaucoup
d'antibiotiques vous avez été très
stressé ce que fut ce matin si vous avez
des métaux lourds des vaccins certains
vaccins des pesticides et cette mutation
du blé vous avez de fortes chances de
déclencher cette maladie est
d'intolérance au gluten et on comprend
aussi que on n'est pas des ruminants
essayez de manger de l'herbe
d'ailleurs vos animaux en mangent de
l'herbe
1 votre chien ils mangent de l'herbe de
temps en temps oui ils mangent de
l'herbe sur pour se purger et l'herbe
elles rentrent comme elle est sorti
parce que nos enzymes digestives ne sont
pas capables de digérer la cellulose
c'est impossible de digérer cette
cellulose et nous nous avons un intestin
qui fait 6 mètres à peu près et qui est
fait pour manger des produits carnés
on évite les mammifères pour manger
certains végétaux cuit pour justement
casser cette cellule aux vous pouvez
prendre des jus de légumes et les
crudités si vous en prenez bien entendu
vous devrez beaucoup les mâcher mais on
mange aujourd'hui beaucoup trop de
fruits et pas assez de légumes
quand vous allez au restaurant il ya une
feuille de salade pittsburgh duel où
vous avez des pommes de terre mais vous
avez rarement des légumes on ne mange
pas assez de légumes donc votre intestin
il va faire 600 m² 600 m² pour tous le
tube digestif et 300 m² d'intestin il ya
ce qu'on appelle le petit intestin sujet
par le temps
il ya le petit intestin et il ya le gros
intestin toute la simulation tout votre
nutrition se fait dans l'intestin grêle
tout où on peut vivre sans colons mais
on ne peut pas vivre sans intestin grêle
on peut vous couper tout le côlon ce
sera pas très pratique parce que comme
les oiseaux dans pas de colomb bas il
faut partout donc on ferait partout donc
il nous faut une petite poche pour
retenir c'est ça c'est surtout à ça que
ça sert parce que la nutrition elle
s'est faite en amont normalement votre
tube digestif votre estomac doit être
totalement stérile il ne doit pas voir
de bactéries et votre grêle il a juste
un petit peu de bactérie dans le fin du
grêle et puis là à droite il ya une
petite poche coups de feu qui qui doit
être étanche et à travers après cette
poche
vous avez le côlon et là c'est des
milliards de bactéries 3 kg 2 à 3 kg de
bactéries dans votre côlon à quoi il
sert ces bactéries elles servent à
amalgamer tous que vous n'avez pas
utilisé pour votre assimilation de
digestion et les mollets et petit à
petit grâce au père et statistques
éviter que ces bactéries stagne et les
éliminer d'accord et tout le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que en balade
tellement fermente tellement avec ces
aliments trop sucrés trop gras mais
aussi surtout avec ces aliments à gluten
lui colle ça colle ça colle à la fois à
la sortie de votre estomac
on s'est amusé avec un gastro
entérologue à prendre un sablier
on a mis une farine avec l'ugtt end dans
un sablier une farine sans gluten et on
retourne la farine avec duten ça colle
ou préfèrent laisser et la farine sans
gluten joue elle colle elle coule dans
votre sortie d'estomac ya le duodénum
et quand justement mange trop de pain de
padt de pizzas et caetera et bien petit
à petit le tuyau va se rétrécir et comme
il va se rétrécir la vidange de
l'estomac ce fait très mal
normalement un estomac il doit être
vidée
à peu près deux heures si votre ville un
geste pas l'estomac ne s'est pas
vidanger après ces deux heures il va se
passer un gros phénomène c'est la
fermentation et à ce moment là on va
être dans une intoxication due dans une
inflammation et c'est la porte ouverte à
beaucoup de maladies donc on a compris
aussi que c'est dans l'intestin grêle
que 95 % de vos neurotransmetteur sont
fabriqués la dépression elle est dans le
ventre
l'escroc tonine elle se fabrique dans le
ventre mais il ya beaucoup de bactéries
bactéries qui mange le tryptophane donc
avant de commencer à faire de la
psychothérapie commencé d'abord à
changer de régime et vous verrez qu'en
éliminant le gluten mais aussi la
caséine bovine et bien vous verrez que
vous irait beaucoup mieux et que vous
n'aurez pas de problèmes psychologiques
ont lâché là j'ai pas le temps
alors sachez vous écoutez moi je préfère
ressembler à suite gauche casud droite
suit droite c'est celui qui est derrière
son ordinateur toute la journée et qui
mangent des sandwiches ou de la
malbouffe et dans quoi trouve-t-on le
gluten penser ça beau s comme seigle a
comme à vannes b comme blé au comme orge
mais aussi qui a muté potro 1 et alors
évidemment vous n'êtes pas le raz de
poser de questions ici mais vous dites
oh c'est pas possible
qu'est ce que je vais manger quoi hein
donc si vous vous posez cette question
c'est que déjà vous mangez trop de
gluten on n'est pas fait pour manger des
céréales les serial de ne sont trop
sucrés de toute façon elle colle et
elles sont très très loin ce chasseur
cueilleur que nous étions vous savez il
ya le régime paléo qui a de plus en plus
des plus en plus en vogue
c'est à dire des petits oiseaux des
poissons des légumes des amendes des
noix des noisettes
on peut quand même manger un petit peu
de sarrasin de des choses sauvage
beaucoup de légumes bien sûr un petit
peu de fruits
méfiez-vous les fruits fermente pour
ceux qui ont tendance à fermenter les
fruits fermentés
donc ça nous laisse beaucoup de choses à
manger ils pouvaient manger du caviar si
ça vous fait plaisir point g des magrets
de canard des confits des choucroutes de
poissons des choses comme ça on a
tellement oublier parce que la société
aujourd'hui nous propose de
l'alimentation facile hop on rentre on
mange un sandwich ou un panini ou une
pizza s'est vite fait on met son opinion
d'' c'est que le micro-etat inverse sa
polarité des cellules 1 et qu'une série
cellule à la sa cohérence et finalement
la bonne santé c'est un système qui doit
être en cohérence entre l'intérieur et
l'extérieur
et pour terminer donc la parole nous est
donnée pour nous exprimer pour passer de
l'intérieur à l'extérieur et c'est pour
ça que nous sommes des êtres de relation
et que ces relations se passe mieux si
on mange sans gluten et sans produits
laitiers parce qu'on est moins irritable
on a plus de vitalité
et finalement on n'est plus disponible
pour les autres voilà je vous remercie
beaucoup